hey
where did you go squirrel
[Music]
on the ground
hush
when sire moves us to the new world
I don't need names
I mean eight nine q one two it's not
really a name
so
I would like my name to be
Lila
[Music]
that's a pretty name Lila
thank you
I think my name shall be Thieves
because although we all do have them
mine are definitely the most prominent
teams thiefs Lila tips
me because floor because me is lying on
floor you're lying on a floor so your
name is floor yeah
oh
what about you friend
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky Lila
tips
and floor
and me
rocket
it really is good to have friends